baby driver is the latest film from one
of my favorite directors Edgar writes
and it stars Ansel Elgort Jamie Foxx
Kevin Spacey Jon Hamm and Jon Bernthal
and our main character in this film is
named baby he likes to make mixtapes out
of conversations that he listens to he's
partially deaf and he just so happens to
be a fantastic getaway driver for
criminals because he's trying to work
off a debt that he has with Kevin
Spacey's character so as you might
expect things go okay for a while he's
earning a lot of money until he meets a
girl and then things go south and we
have some problems that really quick
please stay tuned to the end of this
video because I'm doing something really
cool with Full Sail University they have
an amazing film degree program which I'm
really excited about and I'm going to
talk to you guys about that after the
review naturally I was really excited
for this movie because I would honestly
give every Edgar Wright film so far my
perfect great I adore his films they're
all very fast paced extremely funny
insanely well directed and the editing
is just a beautiful thing to behold so
going to baby driver this early man I
was pumped and it didn't disappoint the
first act of this movie in particular is
essentially filmmaking perfection the
chase sequences are some of the best
I've ever seen and they all look
practical there's a few moments in the
movie that utilized CGI but it is very
very sparse the chase sequence is
featured in this movie are some of the
best ever put the film but the film also
heavily utilizes music in fact in a lot
of ways the film is almost a pseudo
musical while also being a car chase
movie there's a long unbroken take early
in the film where baby is getting coffee
for the other criminals and he's going
through the streets and the song is
playing on his iPod and he's singing
along to it pay attention to the
graffiti that's on the walls behind him
if you look closely you're going to see
some really cool Easter eggs edgar
wright once again has done something
that a lot of people may call style over
substance in fact i would say that's the
main criticism i often hear of his films
which to me i just don't put too much
money on that i think
style is really important it helps
diversify your films from other people's
films so that they were all the same
then that would be boring as and
here his style is
so noticeable instantaneously you don't
even have to know that it's one of his
films and you can just tell instantly
and that's one of the beautiful things
about Edgar Wright as a director and
silly gourd is great his baby now I was
a little concerned about this because I
did think he was fantastic and Fault in
Our Stars but it just felt like the type
of role I didn't expect to see him in
but I wasn't going to complain about it
until I saw the movie and I'm glad that
I didn't because he is really really
good in the action scenes and the more
intense moments but he's also a
character that's very stone cold
he doesn't speak too much but he retains
so much information he can sit down
Kevin Spacey can lay out the entire plan
of their getaway and the job they're
trying to do he won't say a word and
Jamie Foxx had turned him be like I'm
not sure about this guy you know he's
not saying anything and he takes out his
iPod and just repeats the entire plan
instantaneously because he's able to
retain all of that and he really pulled
it off as an actor I thought he was
fantastic in this tone Jamie Foxx also
so frickin good just so sly and cool and
really badass I loved him in this film
and Kevin Spacey also has his signature
way of delivering a lot of dialogues
very fast in a very deadpan manner yet
somehow conveying so much emotion
without really too much expression he's
a very good actor who doesn't act per se
he never tries to overstate himself in a
scene and whenever he's on screen you
just feel that he has the command of the
moment he's fantastic in the film Lily
James plays the love interest that baby
eventually meets halfway through where
things start to get a little topsy-turvy
for him now this is the part of the
movie that I would say is the weakest
after we transition from the opening
first act that is so breathtaking into
the second act which is a lot slower and
this isn't necessarily because there's
no action happening it's basically
because I didn't really feel very
invested in the romance which is a big
problem because it's a major portion of
the film that's supposed to get you to
care about the third act and the romance
was set up so quickly with very little
characterization and not much depth and
she often makes decisions that are
life-altering for a baby that will
change her life and put herself in an
absurd amount of danger and in trouble
with the law in a split second without
much thought so she's either a very
varied
character or this movie is almost like a
fantasy because in certain scenes it
does feel like that the romance just
feels so outlandish and it didn't really
work for me but Jon Hamm and Jamie Foxx
and Kevin Spacey and all these amazing
actors getting really charismatic
performances kept the film interesting
for me even when that romance fell flat
but the third act really picks up once
baby makes some decisions about the way
he wants his life path to be and then we
get a lot of really amazing action
sequences and again still really great
performances and Edgar Wright directed
the out of this movie there's
barely a boring shot everything looks
phenomenal the cinematography and all
the camerawork is top-notch what I think
a lot of people are going to be talking
about once they see this movie is the
soundtrack I won't spoil the song
choices but they're all very unique and
they all have a purpose in the movie and
as I said the movie is almost a pseudo
musical at times and so the songs are
very much so incorporated within the way
certain scenes are edited so that they
flow with the action you're seeing I
really can't wait for you guys to see
those scenes because I found them really
technically impressive so besides the
romance that felt abrupt to me
everything else in baby driver I had a
complete blast with it's another really
entertaining movie from Edgar Wright and
it solidifies if it hasn't already been
solidified his status as one of the best
directors working today I'm going to
give baby driver and a - also it was
great to meet some fans at the screening
Wyatt and Tony thank you so much for
coming up to me guys it was really cool
to talk to you
you guys are awesome thank you for
watching so as I said Full Sail
University got in contact with me and I
want to thank them for sponsoring this
video and what they're doing right now
it's pretty cool I know a lot of my
viewers have a serious interest in
working in the film industry someday and
with full sales digital cinematography
online degree program they merge the
artistic concepts of traditional
filmmaking with the technical tools used
in everything from documentary
filmmaking to commercial production and
web video their bachelor degree program
emerges you in the world of filmmaking
from every angle you'll gain hands-on
experience while learning what it's like
to work on a film from start to finish
giving you a feel for the role each crew
member plays in a production graduates
from Full Sail University have worked on
films and TV shows like Doctor Strange
Star Trek beyond Captain
America Civil War and the walking dead
if you'd like to learn more about Full
Sail University please visit Full Sail
dot edu slash Chris Stockman to learn
more about their degree programs and all
the great things they have to offer for
film lovers like you and me guys thank
you so much as always for watching if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck menage
[Music]
you